[موسيقى]
النكسه اسم دلع اطلقته الانظمه العربيه
على هزيمه حرب العام
1967 مع اسرائيل فيها شارك 500
الف جنديا عربي من جيوش مصر وسوريا
والاردن والعراق ولبنان وبدعم من جيوش
الجزائر والمغرب وتونس وليبيا والسعوديه
والكويت والسودان وباكستان
فاستشهد وفقد 21 الف وعشره جنود واسر
الالاف بينما قتل من الاسرائيليين ما بين
سبعمائه او الف قتيل باختلاف الروايات اي
كانت خسائر العرب اكثر من 21 ضعفا من
خسائر اسرائيل
بالامس قتل الشهيد خيري علقم في القدس
سبعه اسرائيليين فقتل لترتفع خسائر
الاسرائيليين على الفلسطينيين الى سبعه
اضعاف في هذه الموقع لصالح الفلسطينيين
ولينتج خير علقم منفردا عشره بالمئه من
انتاج اجتماع الجيوش العربيه العظمى لكن
مهلا علقم لم يكن في معركه كلاسيكيه بل
قتل مدنيين لا يراهم كثير من العرب مدنيين
فكل مستوطن مسلح وكل محتل مستباح برايهم
فمتى سينتهي الاحتلال ثم المقاومه لتشرق
شمس السلام الى العناوين
بالقدس خير علقم الثاني يثار لخير علقم
الاول
تركيا والامارات تصفان عمليه القدس بانها
ارهابيه
مسيرات عسكريه فوق ايران رسائل ام مفرقعات
ناريه
ما علاقه بوتين بحرق القران في السويد باب
الفاتيكا الشذوذ الجنسي خطيئه لكنه ليس
جريمه
انتخابات تونس بدون ناخبين وسعيد يعتمد
على ماوى العجزه
عبد الفتاح يفاجئ عبد الفتاح باتفاقه مع
ابي احمد
[موسيقى]
بكل احترافيه يرضي الشاب الفلسطيني خير
علقم اكثر من سبعه مستوطنين وجرح اخرين
ينتظرون قدرهم في مستوطنه النبي يعقوب
بالقدس المحتله وكذلك يفعل فتى بعمر
الزهور لم يتعدى 13 عاما بحي سلوان مرحبا
الشهيد خيري علقم والاسير محمود عليوات
واخرون شباب يستعجلون على انفسهم والنهيات
يفارقون الحياه او الحريه بمحض ارادتهم
وهم في عمر الورود لماذا لما هذا الاندفاع
والعجله اسرائيل شخصيا كانت ستاتي اليكم
لتقتلكم في بيوتكم لو طولتوا بالكم شوي
حتى لو لم تفعلوا لها شيئا لكنها كانت
منشغله بمجره جديده لها في جنين يعود مخيم
جنين الى واجهه الصراع الفلسطيني
الاسرائيلي
يقتحم الجيش الاسرائيلي المخيم فيقتل
ويجرح عشرات الفلسطينيين بعد ان دمر واحرق
عدد من المنازل والذريعه ان خلايا داخل
هذه الاحياء كانت تخطط لعمليات ضد اسرائيل
يقولون ان خير علقم قتل مدنيين فيرد
الفلسطينيون بانهم لم يعثروا على مدني
واحد بين المستوطنين كلهم مسلحون ومن فم
نتنياهو ادانوه لقد تعهد برفع مستوى
التسليح الشامل اطرحوه امام الكابينات
اصدار التراخيص حمل السلاح للمواطنين لا
نريد التصعيد لكننا مستعدون لمختلف
السيناريوهات خير علقم الثاني حفيد خير
علقم الاول وبين الجد والحفيد قصه دماء
وقفيه للقدس وفلسطين يقول جيرانهم قتل
الجده مستوطن متطرف لم يعاقب فعاقب الحفيد
به احفادهم مع مفعول رجعي وفوائد ايداع
بنسبه 1000% في مايو
1998 نصب له مستوطنون كمينا واصابوه بعده
طعنات في قلبه فارتقى شهيدا بعد 12 عاما
من استشهاد خير علقم القي القبض على
القاتل ورغم ثبوت التهم براءه القضاء
الاسرائيلي تذكرون مراسل القناه
الاسرائيليه الذي كان مشجعون مونديال قطر
يرفضون التحدث اليه في الدوحه ويطردون
يسالوا في القدس فتن فلسطينيه عن رايه في
الفتى منفذ عمليه سلوان فتمنى المراسل لو
انه طرد ايضا في القدس كما في الدوحه
عمره 13 عام
كيف تعتبره بعتبر بطل جدع بطل اه بطل بطل
بدي اطلع المحتر من ارضه هل تقف السلطه
الفلسطينيه برئاسه الرئيس محمود عباس
عاجزه ازاء ما يحصل حاشا وكلا لقد اوقفت
التنسيق الامنيه الاستخباراتيه مع اسرائيل
لكنه جفاء لا يطول يقول محلل اسرائيلي
فمده صلاحيه السلطه الفلسطينيه بدون الدعم
الاسرائيلي لها لا تتجاوز اسبوعين على
ابعد تقديراته وعلى حد زعمه بدون التعاون
لا يمكن
لمحمود عباس ان يبقى اكثر من اسبوعين
الدول العربيه والاسلاميه المطبعه مع
اسرائيل استنكرت عمليتي القدس لكن تركيا
والامارات
انفردتا بوصف عمليه خير علقم بالعمل
الارهابي وفق ما عبرت وزاره الخ التركيه
وكذلك نظيرتها الاماراتيه في ابوظبي كانت
دوله الامارات بشده الهجوم الارهابي الذي
وقع بالقرب من كنيس في القدس ولكي يكتمل
مشهد الانفصال الشعوري عن الامه كان شخص
اماراتي يدعى احمد يغني في هذا الوقت بدبي
نشيد اسرائيل الرسمي في ذكرى المحرقه
بنشاز استثنائي في الصوت وفي الموقف
[موسيقى]
في البحرين التطبيع تخطى الحكومه ووصل الى
اداره البرلمان عاده الحكومات المطبعه
تدفع ببعض النواب ليعارضوا التطبيع من اجل
سمعه الدوله امام شعبها والشعوب العربيه
اما في مجلس نواب البحرين فيقمع مستشار
لرئيس المجلس غير بحريني يملي على الرئيس
صدم العبارات التي تسيء لاسرائيل في
مداخلات النواب من محضر الجلسه يعني انت
لما جيت تتكلم تقول طيران الخليج يسير
رحلات الى الكيان الصهيوني
من غير مردود من غير ركاب فانا بعرف ليش
التعمد من طيران الخليجي انا ما اظن انه
فيه واحد من شعب البحرين يسافر الى الكيان
الغاصب وهو وهو كيان مجرم هذا الكلمه
معالي الرئيس انا سمعت المستشار ما يمثل
شعب البحرين يقشر لك ويقول لك احذف هذا
المستشار لا يمثل شعب البحرين وهو اساسا
مو بحريني هذا الكيان الاسرائيلي الغاصب
اتمنى
اسرائيل والتي زجت بجيشها في القدس هي
المشتبه به الوحيد في غاره مسيرات علم
منشاه عسكريه داخل ايران الغاره بدون
اضرار تذكر يقول الايرانيون وبين الرسائل
الناريه والالعاب الناريه تفاوت التعليقات
المحللين حسب روايه وزاره الدفاع
الايرانيه فان هجوما غامضا استهدف مصنعا
عسكريا في محافظه اصفهان وسط البلاد تبين
لاحقا انه نفذ بثلاث طائرات مسيره صغيره
رجح نائب محافظه اسفهان في البرلمان
الايراني وقوف اسرائيل وراء الهجوم لكنه
استدرك بالقول انه يجب انتظار نتائج
التحقيق وذاك بعدما كشفه مسؤولون امريكيون
لصحيفه وولد جورنال بان اسرائيل هي من
نفذت الهجوم يقول الايرانيون ان الهجوم
كان فاشلا المحلل السياسي المؤيد للسلطات
الايرانيه عماد ابشناس يحذر قائله من ان
ايران قادره على الرد عليها
بالفلسطينيين وليس بالايرانيه ايران
باستطاعتها ان تقوم بعمليات مشابهه في
الدخل الاسرائيلي لا اتصور ان ايران سوف
يعني تخرب الحفله بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين وسوف تسمح لهم ولربما حتى
تدعمهم
تعطيهم الاسلحه لكي يزيدوا من زخم الحفله
بالنسبه لنتنياهو فريقه في الحكومه
[موسيقى]
انهم يريدون مقدسات المسلمين في اوروبا
باجازات من حكوماتها فهل يرخصون بالمقابل
لاهانه اديان اخرى سؤال لم يعد جوابه
نظريا والجواب كلا قالها سفير اسرائيل لدى
السويد زفني ان تل ابيب والمجتمع اليهودي
السويدي بالتنسيق والتعاون مع مسؤولين
حكوميين سويديين منعوا حرق التوراه امام
مبنى سفاره اسرائيل يقول بعد ان طلب ذلك
شاب اراد اختبار الديمقراطيه الاوروبيه في
السويد طلب الاذن من الشرطه فمنع عنه
الترخيص لحرق الكتاب المقدس عند اليهود لو
طلب حلق المصحف لسبحه له وربما قدموا له
الكبريت او القداحه لكن هل قضوا في السويد
على الاسلام بحرقهم القران
من الانضمام الى حلف الناتو دان اعلن
صراحه عن نيته مواصله حرق نسخ من المصحف
في كل يوم جمعه امام السفاره التركيه في
كوبنهاجن الى حين قبول انقره طلب السويد
لانضمام لحلف الناتو وراء كل بالون صبي
ينفخ فيه اما وراء بالوردان فصحفي يحرضه
ويموله
هو الذي دفع رسمه تصريح الشرطه لحرق
المصحف لكنه تنصل منه بعد غضب العالم
الاسلامي تشانغ فريك الذي يختبئ اليوم في
مواقع اعلاميه مواليه لليمين المتطرف
افادت صحيفه تيليجراف البريطانيه بانه عمل
سابقا في وسائل اعلام روسيه حكوميه وبانه
مفتون بفلاديمير بوتين ويعتبره رئيسه
الحقيقي امل ان يقرا بالودان القران بدلا
من حرقه لكن هل تعلمون ان قائل الجمله ومن
حرض على التظاهر وهو الشخص الذي مولها
ايضا ودفع تكاليفها خرج يلوم الفاعل
ويتهمه بالغباء لكن ما علاقه روسيا وبوتين
تحديدا بهذا الحدث الذي قامت الدنيا ولم
تقعد بسببه على السويد ومقابل تعبيره عن
استيائه وندمه على ما حصل تداولت صحف انه
كان يعرف بالضبط ما يفعل وانه يعمل لصالح
روسيا في هذا الموضوع خاصه انه موظف سابق
في واحده من اكبر القنوات الروسيه وله
تغريدات كثيره عبر تويتر نشر فيها صوره
وهو يرتدي قمصانا عليها صور للرئيس الروسي
بوتين وفي احدى تصريحاته بالماضي قال
حرفيا ها هو رئيس الحقيقي هذا هو بوتين ما
شكل شبهات حول انه مدفوع من جهه الروسيه
لاحداث هذه البلبله ضد السويد
ذلك لعرقله دخولها في حلف الناتو تبقى
معلومات واستنتاجات يسال عنها اصحابها او
تسال عنها ايضا حكومه فنلندا التي المحت
بدورها الى تورط روسيا في واقعه حرق
القران الكريم في السويد بهدف توسيع الهوه
بينها وبين تركيا وبالتالي اخراجها من
مسار الانضمام الى حلف الناتو في صفوف
المسلمين باوروبا تعلو الان اصوات تحت
شعار اعرض عن الجاهلين تدعو الى تجاهل
العاهات المتطرفه التي تسيء الى الاسلام
فما رايكم هل تؤيدون فكره التجاهل ام
تدعمون التصدي للاساءات الى المقدسات
بالكلمه والتظاهر السلمي دونوا ان رغبتوا
بعد
في مقابل التطرف اليميني يقرر الرئيس
الوزراء الكندي المتسامح جوستانتريدو
تعيين الصحفيه المسلمه امير الجواب ممثله
للدوله الكنديه لتنسيق جهود مكافحه
الاسلام وفوبيا والعنصريه وعدم التسامح
الديني في البلاد فهل تستغربون بعد ذلك
تسميه مهاجر سوري طفله على اسم الرئيس
تريدو عرفانا بجميله في رعايه اللاجئين
الى كندا في وقت يرمون فيه ببعض بحور
اوروبا المستعمره لبلدانهم في افريقيا
وغيرها وهذا اسمه جاستن ترودو ابني
في الهند الصوره مظلمه مع حمله اعتقالات
واسعه لطلاب جامعيين اعترضوا على حظر
الحكومه تداول وثائقي انتجته هيئه الاذاعه
البريطانيه يكشف تورط الرئيس الوزراء
في مذابح اباده طائفيه ضد المسلمين قبل
عقدين من امام جامعه
عرض السلطات الهنديه لوثائقي اعدته البي
بي سي
الوثائقي تحدث عن دور المحتمل لرئيس
الوزراء الهندي نارين درامودي في اعمال
شغب طائفيه وقعت في عام 2002 وادت الى
مقتل الف شخص غالبيتهم من المسلمين بعد
جرائمهم هل يحج القتله الى نهر الجانجل
المقدس والمكدس فيه ما يتبقى من الجثث
المحروقه هذا الاسبوع كان موسم حج الهندوس
الى نهر الجانج وصلنا الاغرب مدينه هنا في
الهند رجال الدين فيها الجثث ورجال الدين
فيها بياكلوا كمان من لحم الجثث في بعض
الاحيان هم يعتقدوا ان طريقه الحرق هذه
يقطعوا بها علاقه الروح بالجسد ولما تنذر
قدام النهر المقدسه متاعهم هذه طريقهم الى
الخلاص في المتفرقات يقولوا راس الكنيسه
الكاثوليكيه في العالم بابا الفاتيكان
فرنسيس ان الشذوذ الجنسيه خطيئه لكنه ليس
جريمه وانتقد القوانين التي تجرم المثليه
الجنسيه
على الكنيسه الكاثوليكيه الغاؤها واضاف
ايضا كما ينبغي على الاساقفه الكاثوليك
الذين يدعمون القوانين المناهضه للمثليه
الترحيب بالمثليين داخل الكنيسه من دون
عقود عمل واحيانا لا يتلقون اجورهم عنوان
تقرير لقناه فرنسيه وليس قطريه يكشف
استغلال فرنسا للعمال الافارقه الذين
يعملون في منشات الالعاب الاولمبيه لدوره
باريس
2024 فاين اصبحت ترعه حقوق العمال التي
اشارتها فرنسا في وجه قطر خلال مونديال
الدوحه يسال اللاعب الدولي السابق ابراهيم
سيام
فليتفقدوا منزلهم يقول قبل ان يفتشوا بيوت
الاخرين
بعد اتمام الانتخابات البرلمانيه التونسيه
الحوار الان في تونس ليس على شرعيتها
الشعبيه المفقوده بالارقام بل على نسبه
السقوط السلطه تقول انها بلغت 11 وشوي
بالميه بينما تقول المعارضه
3% باكثر الاحصائيات تفاؤلا فلنقل انها 11
فاصل في المئه يعني ان حوالي 90% وتسعه
وثمانين في المئه من الشعب التونسي ومره
اخرى قال بانه لا ينخرط في هذا المسلسل
الانقلابي على القناه الحكوميه فضيحه
مباشره على الهواء باستضافه بسنه مريضه
ومقعده احضرت مع اقرانها من دار المسنين
للاقتراع ولو الحجه لوحدها غابت كانت
النسبه تدنيت تبع دار المسنين
تواكب العمليه الانتخابيه اليوم جيت
انتخبت
ني
قبل اقل من ثلاث سنوات كانت السلطه
العسكريه الحاكمه في السودان تقول ان حرب
المياه قادمه مع اثيوبيا بسبب سد النهضه
فجاه وبدون مقدمات تصبح الخرطوم متفقه مع
اثيوبيا حول كافه قضايا سد النهضه بحسب
الجنرال عبد الفتاح البرهان دون تقديم
اضاحات كافيه نحن اتفقنا في كل الامور
كلما ناقشناه من امر لم نجد اي اختلاف او
اي خلاف في اي من امورنا شدد البرهان خلال
لقائه ابي احمد على ضروره تعزيز التعاون
والتنسيق بين البلدين في القضايا الثنائيه
اقليميا ودوليا مؤكدا بان الخرطوم واداه
صبابه متوافقتان ومتفقتان بشان جميع
القضايا المتعلقه بسد النهضه حضرتك مش عم
تعمل لايك على تغريده لابي احمد او لابو
احمد يا زول المساله تتعلق بازمه وجوديه
للسودان في القاهره لم يكونوا مسرورين
ابدا باستداره البرهان فجاه فوجئنا بان
السيد ابي احمد والسيد علي البرهان بيقول
لك ان احنا حلينا كل حاجه بما فيها
المشاكل اللي موجوده في سد النهضه كلها
تماما الله اي خلل
في الكميه اللي هتبقى 74 مليار متر مكعب
هتشيل السودان ومش عايزين حد يعني يتفقوا
من ورانا لان مصر في الحقيقه في
دبلوماسياتها بتتعامل بمثاليه ربما يكون
اكثر من مما ينبغي الدوله المصريه الحقيقه
صبرها طال باكثر مما ينبغي
هلا يا عم المدينه خاصه اسمها باب الحاره
محمد قنبض نائب سوري ورجل اعمال ومنتج
مسلسل باب الحاره وموزع سندويشات وماء
مقابل الهتاف للاسد هل تذكرون
رئيس جمهوريه باب الحاره محمد قمبض يرد
على الممثل ياسر العظمه بعد انتقاده مسلسل
باب الحاره بانه يتفهم انتقاده فهو يريد
الشهره على حساب قنبض والعظمه غيران لانه
لم يمنح فرصه المشاركه في المسلسل
قمبض لفظ كلمه الترند ريند فقط لتشكيل
فكره عما يوجه الدراما العربيه نستمع الى
رد قنبض واتهام العظمه
[موسيقى]
باب الحقيقه باب الحاره يلي عم يحاولوا
جهدهم يعملوا منه امام المسلسلات السوريه
بما يحمله من تاريخ مزور وافتراء سافر على
حقبه مهمه من تاريخ سوريا باب الحاره يزور
تاريخ سوريا براي ياسر العظمه وياسر
العظمه يزور حاضره سوريا براي الناشطين
السوريين فهو اعتبر من نفس الكرسي ان سبب
تهجير اكثر من نصف الشعب السوري فقر الحال
تخيلوا ما في عاقل بزت حاله بالبحر
وبيركب قارب الموت هو واولاده الصغار
ومرته مسكينه حبا بالمغامره يعني اذا وطنك
خبز
ولا عم يحقق لك متطلبات لحياه الضروريه من
غاز وكهرباء ودواء وماء وتعليم وعمال تاكل
منه عيش وتامن على اسرتك وعيالك وبيتك
فاكيد رح تلاقي الهجره هي الخلاص يقول
الرئيس بوتين لماذا سيبقى العالم اذا لم
تكن روسيا فيه وفقراء مخيمات القهر
السوريه يقولون لبوتين ولنا ولغيرنا ما
نفع العالم اذا كنتم انتم فيه كلهم
دفيانين الا نحن
[موسيقى]
يعني
بدي كتير
[موسيقى]
ختاما كان اسد الغابه يحتضر فاستدعى شبله
الذي سيرث الحكم بعد موته ووصاه بان لا
يتخذ بطانه له الا من الحمير وان يبعد عنه
السباع حتى لو اضطر الى قتلهم او نفيهم او
اعتقالهم ساله الشبل لما يا ابتي فاجاب
لانك يا بني حمار بثوب اسد اذا ابتعدت عن
الاسود ستظنك عن بعد مثلها واذا اقتربت من
الحمير ستحبك كثيرا ستعتبرك واحدا منها
ستدين لك بالولاء وتفديك بارواحها
التزم الشبل نصيحه ابيه ومنذ ذلك الحين
والبطانات تزدحم بالحمير الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]